tents have been erected to deal with the
overflow inside the sick layin weight
worried parents watching on the
Philippines has been gripped by a
measles outbreak erlin Rubeus two
month-old baby caught the highly
infectious virus before he was old
enough to be vaccinated
[Music]
my baby had a lot of rashes I thought it
was because he was taking antibiotics
for his coffin colds but it turned out
to be measles it's already painful to
see your baby sick
what more when you hear that many have
died from the disease you don't want
that to happen to your baby there have
been more than eight thousand cases of
measles in the Philippines since the
start of the year more than a hundred
people have died mostly very young
children who are unvaccinated the Health
Department has declared a measles
outbreak and says that it is now
struggling to contain it it's really a
need to do catch-up activities
because the challenge is to attain herd
immunity herd immunity means that you
have enough people who are vaccinated so
that those who are not vaccinated are
unable to transmit their missiles virus
and in fact others immunization rates in
the Philippines have been dropping in
the last few years
a recent scare involving a dengue
vaccine caused immunization rates to
plummet even further
these are a myriad of reasons why we
have a low vaccine coverage in 2018 it
even went out to 40% efforts to tip the
scales haven't been fast enough
Charmaine Abad thought she been
immunized but picked up the virus while
at a health center for a prenatal
checkup measles can be extremely
dangerous for pregnant women I'm scared
about what will happen to my baby but
I'm trying to be strong my doctor said
the condition shouldn't affect the baby
because I'm at 32 weeks already but I'm
scared
look Allah thora teas are working with
the Red Cross to increase hospital beds
for those affected and immunize as many
people as possible to try and contain
the outbreak mothers like Angela assured
ou are not taking any more chances the
news about kids dying from the dengue
fever vaccination scared me
so I was scared to have my children
vaccinated
[Music]
but now I know it's for their own safety
immunization rates are steadily rising
again health authorities hoped that the
continued confidence in vaccines will
help stem this measles outbreak joining
me to talk more about this is Richard
Gordon chairman of the Philippine Red
Cross in Manila Richard give us some
context how bad is this outbreak
well the outbreak spreads very fast now
it's several regions of the country
particularly the two regions immediately
close to Metro Manila which are heavily
populated and now we have about 14 1
more 15,000 people 14,000 cases affected
by measles and about 238 people dead
when you consider the fact that last
year they were 202 dead
we just finished February which is only
two months we already always shot to
death last year the numbers keep going
higher and higher now a correspondent in
the report talks about the dengue fever
vaccine and fears over that is that one
reason that's driving a lot of parents
from vaccinating their children in
general in the Philippines yes that's
one major reason
Sanofi push the product upon the front
piece put out a lot of vials and then it
turns out that there are some questions
about the drug and a lot of people died
outdoors there's some point of this
theory that followed understandably but
of course there so there's no decision
yet on whether in fact they were killed
by Santa Fe but nonetheless a lot of
people were turned off with that now
what does the Filipino government need
to do to reverse this trend to convince
people to get their children vaccinated
and to solve the current problem
good job we're helping them we're
telling them that this is these diesel
sharks are charged that they would
administrate for the last so many years
it's why they expanded
expanded immunization plan unlike then
unlike the grass shell which is a force
experiment upon us so a lot of people
are now concerned because uh they see a
lot of people that have died and they're
not going back and coming in and weren't
in the Red Cross we have full court
press house trials inoculations are
going on as well as the Department of
Health at the local government which is
really the front line
you know initiator of acid vaccination
well you know when we devolve hours from
the National Guard to the local
government there is slow on the uptake
so we have to rush for that okay well
Richard Gordon thank you very much
you